[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy taco tuesday
it is taco tuesday isn't it
i believe it is
anyone else have tacos every tuesday
on taco tuesday
good morning everybody
good morning good morning good morning
debbie good morning kathy good morning
david christina robin is here
everyone is here we have a lot of news
to get to today um it looks like oh
they're the vladimir putin is terrified
of democracy
so he's going to punish
alexey navalny moore
uh mike flynn uh of course he's a
sycophant
uh he's supporting putin
not a surprise
we have a whole list of traitors to
democracy this morning eric trump tucker
carlson
the list goes on and on and on and on
that's why i made the theme for today
traitors
of democracy
to democracy excuse me traitors too
because it's not just our democracy
it's not just our democracy that the
traders do
they just don't like democracy in
general
like in general they don't like
democracy
that's how it goes
good morning mayo nolan's here
kalin's here good morning good morning
everyone
good
morning
good morning
we do have a lot of news
again to get to today now a lot of stuff
trending
most of it again is
american traders
to russia
uh it's also equal pay day
uh
the president of ukraine meets with the
canadian parliament uh liz cheney is
trending i don't know why i have no idea
uh biden and blinking are
are trending because they've been
sanctioned
oh
russia's gonna sanction hunter buttons
laptop
all the the right wingers the trump
pumpers will get a big kick a big kick
out of vladimir putin and russia
sanctioning
hunter biden's laptop and hillary
clinton's emails too apparently i guess
that's what they're saying this morning
they're gonna sanction hillary clinton's
emails and hunter biden's laptop fox
news will be completely excited tucker
carlson won't be able to hide his putin
boner tonight
on russia tonight with tucker carlson
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know
russian television russian state
television rt doesn't even have to
produce content anymore like they don't
have to produce content oh my god we'll
just
we'll just tap into fox news's feed
that's what we'll do we'll just do that
or mike lindell tv and we'll do that too
just feed right into those loops steve
bannon's trader tv will just feed right
into that loop they don't even need they
don't even have to have news cash like
they don't even have to have people who
work anymore
now that they've discovered that people
are gonna protest live on air
i don't have anyone with a sign behind
me that says no to war i mean i would
put someone behind me that would say no
to war
i'm all for the note of war thing
apparently russian tv is not
kind of pissed off
or pissed off
that russians are
dissenting
vladimir putin
and uh the the the
the russian authoritarians want to make
sure that alexi navali navalny spends 13
more years in prison i wonder if putin's
doing math he's like look
i got at least
13 years so let's give him 13 years that
will lock up alexey navalny that way
democracy cannot cannot take hold here
in russia
i guess i don't know i don't know what
what's the arbitrary 13 years that they
want to give navalny
i i tweeted this morning
be navalny i think that hashtag should
start trending
be navalny hashtag b
robin says they've only sanctioned
democrats
and hunter biden's laptop robin hunter
biden's laptop probably doesn't have any
kind of
you know party affiliation
maybe i don't know
i mean i i always i always try to make
hunter binds laptop have like human
qualities because they do like they
think it's like it has secrets on it and
it tells secrets and it sends secrets
and they're gonna lock up they're gonna
lock up hunter biden's laptop
i don't know how many times i got to go
through this with the hunter biden thing
even vladimir putin even vladimir putin
understands
the trump sheep right
he gets it he gets the manga sheep
he gets it he's like ah we'll just throw
these buzzwords in hillary clinton
hunter biden
we'll just throw that in the memo
that'll really get him all [ __ ]
stirred up
that'll really get fox news going
produce us some content for rt that way
we don't have to spend so much goddamn
time producing content jesus christ
we're trying to figure out how our
military is even going to survive the
ukrainian army
we'll see
we'll see
no one lines up have you noticed this
because we we went through uh the don jr
video yesterday speaking of the trump
brothers we're gonna get to eric trump
he's still trending
but we went to the don jr the new don
junior video about how he [ __ ]
doesn't understand now oil prices work
or
that putin has a lot to do with oil
prices right now like that's a lot to do
with it like right in this moment
like gas prices are always affected by
different things in this moment right
now as the world is concerned
the war in ukraine where putin is the
aggressor he is the one committing war
crimes
the rest of the world cutting off
russian oil
is affecting
gasoline prices at the pump not just
here you [ __ ] boneheads
it's not just here
it's it's all around the world it's
affecting gas prices you dumb bucks
these these people who claim
to be free market capitalist
and then don't even [ __ ] understand
how simple supply and demand actually
works like they're they're just unaware
and really honestly the crude oil prices
are much more compliment complicated
than just supply and demand you have a
lot of uh
you know forces working in
in those areas like opec
as we see maybe where there's some deals
being made with venezuela and saudi
arabia but
we'll get back to that
these people who claim to be free market
capitalists who love capitalism who love
the free market
they they they don't even spend enough
time to figure out how it actually works
like at all
like at all
but that's neither here nor there
so gas prices are rising
now the country is getting a little sick
and tired of it but
i would say
of course it affects your pocketbook
but who should we be mad at who should
we not be mad at let me tell you
something the people you should be mad
at
trump humpers out there who think it's
joe biden's fault the democrats
had a bill
i called it the big
bird
bill is what i called it that's what i
called it it was called bill back better
but again we can go on and on and on
about how stupid that name was
but the big bird bill actually had
inflation protection to be extended in
it
democrats
the pro-democracy party in this country
were the only ones in congress and the
senate fighting for average americans to
get inflation protection
by the way of the child tax credit
hundreds of dollars
was being dumped
into average
americans accounts who had families
that was inflation protection
from the the
the [ __ ] absolute disaster that the
last [ __ ] idiot put us through
by destroying our economy
by not taking the pandemic [ __ ]
seriously
and doing the things that needed to be
done to save our economy in that time
did we see any republicans vote for
inflation protection
it was almost a year ago folks
almost a year ago
when the pro-democracy party in this
country decided that yes because of the
pandemic
because the last [ __ ] [ __ ] it
up so bad that we will extend inflation
protection in the way of the child tax
credit we will flood the economy with
money and give people the inflation
protection within them and their
families now i think i personally think
we should give inflation protection to
every american
and everyone who's here
give them inflation protection sure why
not
so you're telling me you're going to be
against inflation protection to help you
to help you get through these high gas
prices
i mean you think joe biden can turn up
the gas prices why can't he give you
money to turn him down huh
that's what you want right you want a
president of the united states who can
control costs control goods and control
services
why not be able to dump money in your
account huh
you [ __ ] idiot who has a truck that's
oversized and gets five miles to the
gallon when you haul nothing
and you're complaining and bitching
about gas prices you're driving around
dc over and over and over making loops
on the beltway
ah
these these mandates
that you're putting on me
i'm a white man
all these mandates that are on me and
the gas prices so what i'm gonna do is
is use my freedom
to travel
to drive around
the capital of the united states
and
clog up a little bit of traffic
and spend more money on gasoline and
diesel that way the price of crude goes
up
which i'm protesting it makes no sense
it really doesn't make no sense but if
you if you bonehead really do think that
gas prices are too high and the
president united states joe biden or
whoever the [ __ ] the president is it
doesn't matter who the prison is
it doesn't [ __ ] matter daffy duck joe
biden it doesn't donald trump it doesn't
matter
they don't control the price of gasoline
at the pump
that's not how it [ __ ] works
they don't have a gasoline button
as i said yesterday it would be kind of
cool though if the president unite would
it be cool if the president united
states actually had a gasoline button
on their desk that'd be pretty [ __ ]
sweet
i'm just saying i mean donald trump had
a diet coke button why shouldn't the
president have a gasoline button
right i think we should put install a
gasoline button on the president's desk
he can just make the price of gas
whatever the [ __ ] he wants whatever the
[ __ ] she wants for that matter
for future presence because that's where
we need to get to we need to get to
where women
are president united states quick
fasting in a [ __ ] hurry here
men just [ __ ] this thing up
and they keep [ __ ] it up
and it continues to be men that are
[ __ ] this whole thing up
not just here all around the world
but it would be awesome it would be
really [ __ ] cool if there was like a
dial i don't know what it looks like
maybe it's like the old tv dial
you know where you turn it up volume
maybe
you know where you just you twist it or
it can be like a toggle switch where you
gotta go back and forth you know what i
mean i'm just saying
i'm just saying if they want the
president united states to have a
gasoline button maybe we should give
them one maybe we should give the
president united states the gasoline
button that they want them to have
and then see how the [ __ ] they like it
see how they like how that works
how their non-capitalist
gasoline button on the president's desk
would work
it really is [ __ ] stupid
but yes are americans having to pay more
in fuel absolutely
and the only ones that are willing to do
anything about it in this country were
democrats
and i think they should still be pushing
it today
they should carve out
they should carve out inflation
protection
out of the bill
pass it in the house send it to the
senate
and call it the gasoline relief act
the gas act i don't know
i'm calling on congress today
as if they [ __ ] listen to me
why not
why not why not have
why not have
a gasoline
supply inflation protection act whatever
you want to say
where we give every american
a certain amount of money just like we
did
we can do it we we did it before we did
it for a whole year and no one [ __ ]
no one batted an eye not one
[ __ ] do you notice that not one
[ __ ] batted and i
we were giving families hundreds of
dollars every single month thousands of
dollars every month
thousands of dollars a year
not one [ __ ] bad and deny we
could do it
absolutely we could do it why couldn't
we
sure why not
the gas act
should be called the putin price hike
act
the putin price hike
inflation protection act i don't know
come up with some kind of [ __ ] name
that's got an acronym or some [ __ ] just
call it the gas act
this is what democrats do that's what
they do
it's the gas
act do that
get to it [ __ ]
democrats show them show them that you
want to [ __ ] give them money for the
gas that's what these morons want
which that's what americans should want
i mean that's fine by me
i'm okay with helping average americans
with the gasoline price
as we fend off
a [ __ ] authoritarian who is murdering
women and children and committing war
crimes
i mean if we're not gonna go over there
and fight which i don't know if we
should or we shouldn't it's kind of
you know on the edge right now we're
getting there
but if we're not gonna fight there we
might as well fight here
make it easier for people to buy gas
increase our economy [ __ ] putin [ __ ] him
and [ __ ] anyone who who
who cow talents to that [ __ ]
including tucker carlson and mike flynn
those pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
same way with eric trump sean hannity
all of them every last one of them i
guess brian kilmer was on there
genuflecting to putin this morning too i
don't know we're going to get to that
brian killman is [ __ ] trending too
i'm sure he was genuflecting i have i
haven't went in the thread yet but i'm
sure that's what happened
i'm almost positive
it's hard it's it's not hard to guess
why don't we do that why don't we get to
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
and we'll see
what's on the [ __ ] list let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome to the [ __ ] list
round up the portion of the show where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
and boy are there some trends today
there wasn't a lot trending this morning
i mean other than eric trump being a
doofus
on fox news talking about [ __ ] he
doesn't understand in a way that he
doesn't he can't talk about it but you
know whatever
and i'm sure we'll get to that
but we got a lot of stuff going on uh
again we got equal pay day
uh there's the canadian parliament brian
kilmain again is trending
maybe still uh liz cheney the yen is
trending eric trump i'm biden and
blinking
yeah i think gabe's going to join us too
i'm not sure let's let me let me let me
see
see if we can
when he's going to jump in here
we'll save the eric trump stuff for um
for gabe gabe loves eric oh he's a big
fan of eric
as you know he's played eric on the show
all right let's let's go to the timeline
here
did
looks like he's going to join us here in
about 10 minutes
for a little while
let's see come on
everyone's liking the trucker convoy
video it's still going
it's still going everyone still likes it
here's the russian sanction list
um
joe biden
is on the list
secretary of state anthony blinken
pentagon chief lloyd austin
assistant to the president for national
security jake sullivan the cia director
william burns
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
mark milley
oh and the white house press secretary
jen dunk on ducy sake
deputy assistant of to the president of
national security
duleep singh
director of the agency of international
development samantha power
and then this one's really weird
all of a sudden you know like all these
all these like the president the
secretary of state
the pentagon chief like these are all
members of the administration right
completely understand why putin would be
so scared of the administration that he
would start trying to sanction them
saying oh i'm rubber you're glue what
bounces off me sticks to you you know
it's that it's the normal authoritarian
trump like [ __ ]
you know come back it's always the
comeback that these [ __ ]
[ __ ] artists have trump's always got
it i'm rubber you're glue what bounces
off me sticks to you
right that's what it is
but here in high fashion it says son of
the u.s president hunter biden
i mean i would figure
i would figure
and and maybe if i'm kamala harris i'm
like what the [ __ ]
why ain't i what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
me i'm not on this goddamn list
come on
the the son of the president united
state what
hunter biden
former us secretary of state and former
presidential candidate they made sure
not to leave that out that
we
we supported trump and the united states
voted for him because we did a psy up
hillary clinton's emails is on
the sanctions list
u.s first secretary is secretary of
state
and that president and chairman of board
of directors of import export bank
but i believe
all right here's the thing
here's the thing
this this this double-sided talk [ __ ] is
is just getting ridiculous and i'm sure
average americans don't
aren't aware that this is going on i
mean a lot of average americans you know
they're worried about tom brady retiring
and then coming back and retiring and
coming back but they they don't they
don't even know who the [ __ ]
secretary of state is they don't even
know who the chairman of joint chiefs of
staff is they don't know who the
pentagon chief is [ __ ] they don't even
know who the secretary of state is
half of them and the only reason why
they know who joe biden is because
there's a sticker on the gas pump
it's the truth it's sad but it's [ __ ]
true
it's sad but it's true
but this double-sided talk stuff here's
what i'm saying
hunter biden is either a [ __ ]
coked out cracked out dude who can't get
out of bed in the morning
can't even manage to leave his hotel
room or whatever the [ __ ] they say out
there whatever the [ __ ] they spent
out there about 100 i'm not saying he's
he's an upstanding guy i mean that
hunter biden the nice part about hunter
biden is he's nowhere near the white
house that's kind of cool like that's
that's kind of cool
you know considering the last [ __ ]
guy
but hunter biden he cannot be this evil
maniacal guy who's who's trying to take
over the world
you know by being the son of the present
united states and using his laptop
to advance the cabal
and make sure
that autocracy is toppled
it can't be [ __ ] both he's either a
worthless piece of [ __ ] or he's not
i mean i i don't believe
i actually don't believe that don jr is
worth a [ __ ]
like he's not worth a [ __ ] i actually
don't believe that i believe the reason
one reason why the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup it was just an attempt and it
didn't work because you had a bunch of
[ __ ] doofuses trying to take over the
constitution in the united states yes
they tried to overthrow our government
they committed what i see as treason
but they're doofuses it doesn't mean
they're not doofuses
right
that may be the reason why it didn't
[ __ ] work
can you imagine if you had people who
actually could put some thoughts
together
that could manage to organize a
successful campaign
to overthrow a government we would have
been [ __ ]
she had a bunch of doofuses
so this double-sided talk how hunter
biden is some kind of worthless
[ __ ] who can't get out of bed
because he's all coked up drugged up
with hookers
all drunk
he can't manage to roll out of bed
or he's taking over the world it cannot
be both
that's the same [ __ ] about how joe
biden's woke we say it all the time on
here joe biden's walk but he's sleepy
which is it dumb [ __ ]
which is it
which is it it's the same thing you see
at these rallies when like walter
masterson or the good liars ask these
people who the president is or like oh
joe biden's not actually the president
it's donald trump he's running the
country from mar-a-lago and joe biden is
just all fake to to [ __ ] fool you
and then they're like but the the gas
prices are are are the president's fault
right yeah they're job but joe biden's
not the president yeah but he is the
president it's really complicated see
the facebook ivermectin institute group
told me it's complicated
dumb [ __ ] the other thing too
is hillary clinton
hillary clinton cannot be some evil
maniacal person
and and
taking over the world and controlling
the entire world and killing off people
who get in her way and didn't win the
[ __ ] presidential race
you do understand that right
you do get it right
oh the double-sided talk so here we have
the president united states the
secretary of state joe
joe biden and anthony blinken also
hunter biden's laptop
and hillary clinton's emails are
sanctioned
official sanctioned
by the russian diplomatic department
a stop list as it were
oh [ __ ]
can't make this [ __ ] up you cannot make
this [ __ ] up all right let's go down the
timeline here
here's pager takes
with michael flynn that piece of [ __ ]
traitor to democracy
this theme is gonna be heavy today i
have a feeling that's why i made it the
title traitors to democracy episode 96
isn't that crazy
every single weekday we are here live
noon eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch and this is episode 96
96 times i've been yelling and screaming
in the microphone
we're almost to a hundred should we do
something special for a hundred i don't
know what should we do what do you guys
want to do for a hundred episodes
want to have a big party
i i don't know maybe we can have like a
virtual
party thing
i don't know what do you guys think we
do for a hundred episodes
go down to the comments below here let
me let me let me do the youtube thing
correctly go down to the comments below
and put what you want in the 100
episodes
and those of you on that listening on
the podcast directors whether it be
spotify google apple wherever you listen
to you do the podcast
come to the youtube video to the youtube
channel subscribe subscribe to i'm
trying to do the youtube thing right
here subscribe to the youtube channel
click like
and comment down below what you want us
to do for the 100 episodes
everyone's saying you're in the chat
a virtual party they want to have a
virtual party i don't know
you guys want to get drunk virtually i
don't know how this works
all right let's
let's get back to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
michael flynn says ukraine's
independence is not vital to the united
states
so in that case since it's not vital to
us
and and our freedom which it completely
is 100 is that's what nato is you dumb
[ __ ]
the whole point is is that you would
[ __ ] defend democracy rather it has
it rather it's here or there
again i said this before do you guys i'm
old enough to [ __ ] remember when the
republican party had a president
from texas he was a governor for a long
time his name was george w bush
he he his whole [ __ ] presidency the
whole bush doctrine was to spread
democracy throughout the world right
like in a nutshell that was the bush
doctrine if you got a government we want
it to be a democracy
and if it's not a democracy we'll make
it a democracy like that was the whole
point
that was it
that was the [ __ ] republican party
and tell trump
and tell trump
and then no go
and with trump you get michael flynn a
trader like michael finn you get a
trader like steve bannon you get a
trader like his sons eric and don
you get traders like tucker carlson
who would sell out
their their country
sell out democracy altogether and the
reason why is because fascism
it doesn't it doesn't go well with
democracy right fascism just doesn't go
well we see we see the fascism that's
happening all around the country that
they want to institute in our country
where women in missouri they can't they
can't have an eptopic pregnancy you
can't
your body needs to find a whole way to
shut that whole thing down women
even though these guys
these white ball sacks writing these
bills have no idea what a [ __ ]
eptopic pregnancy is let alone a [ __ ]
pregnancy
they don't know what it is
they don't
know anyone who looks like me should not
be legislating a womb
i don't have one i don't know anything
about the [ __ ]
maybe maybe just maybe
when you take your car to the mechanic
you should look for the mechanic who
knows mechanics
you don't take your car to the ice cream
shop dummies
but they're trying to take our liberty
all around the country and it's not just
gonna stop at children it's not just
gonna stop at lgbtq it's not just gonna
stop at women and and people who are
pregnant
rather that pregnancy is viable or gonna
kill them
they're not they've abandoned the whole
[ __ ] right to life movement
in one fell swoop
in missouri
a woman
who has an eptopic pregnancy and for
anyone out there who doesn't know you
[ __ ] dudes out there who don't know
what a [ __ ] eptopic pregnancy is it's
not actually a pregnancy meaning it's
not viable it's not gonna work that
baby's not gonna be born it's not a
thing you don't need and really you
don't need to know how it works there's
plenty of professionals out there
there's plenty of doctors
there's plenty of science behind it
you don't need to know every single
detail you just need to know one [ __ ]
thing
one thing about an ectopic pregnancy
the person who is having that eptopic
pregnancy life is at risk they will die
that's all you need to know
that's it
that's the only thing you need to know
that's it
you will die from it the person who has
an ectopic pregnancy will [ __ ] die
from it
that's all you need to know you don't
need to know anything else you don't
need to know how many weeks how many
days you know
was it the sex that caused this
was it that you know i had feelings
about a person and i seen them face to
face at church
and we were talking about things
things happen
you don't need to know any of that you
don't need to know about condoms you
don't need a blog about birth control
you don't you don't even need to know
about deliveries of babies at this point
you just need to know one [ __ ] thing
when a person has an eptopic pregnancy
it will [ __ ] kill them
and yeah okay you call it an abortion
yeah you call it a pregnancy but it's
not
it's [ __ ] not
it's what the doctors in science call it
that's what they call it
but it's not that
it's not so stop trying to legislate
[ __ ] you don't know
but this is what they want this is the
fascism they want they want to take away
our liberty they want to take it away
gabe is joining us here
gabe
how are you this morning i'm on a rant
i'm on a rant right now i i saw that i i
caught a brief moment of uh of that
green room there we are uh
we're talking about traitors to
democracy and it's like the whole
republican party well that's why i had
the theme this way this morning i don't
know maybe i should just we should just
change the name of the show traitors to
democracy yeah let's bring them up i
mean that's what we do every day here it
seems like that's like the reoccurring
theme every [ __ ] day there every yes
every day uh
it is something new you know whether
it's uh
[Music]
whether you know it could be eric trump
thinking that his dad would stamp to
putin because he was a tough man or it
could be
uh you know it could be florida or it
could be texas or it could be someone
other my great state of missouri who is
trying to make it to where uh a woman
can't leave the state to have a medical
procedure right you know the state of
texas wants to
this is this is the this is like i can't
even get my [ __ ] head around this
pro-lifers the right to life movement in
texas
wants to make sure that if a woman has a
medical procedure they can kill her
this this is this is supposed to be
pro-life this is supposed to be the
right to the right
they don't care they don't care well i
mean it's been this way for a long time
yeah i can't remember what episode
because it's been it's been 96 episodes
by the way i can't remember whatever
yeah i know we're almost to 100.
everyone says we should have a big party
with booze and
uh some people are saying boobs even i
don't know if we can do that i don't
know if we can do that i don't know if
that's uh that's appropriate i don't
know
remind me of boobs here in a minute and
we'll talk about uh your instagram
account uh anyways
anyway
anyways uh
uh oh yes back to the right to life
movement right i i made a point um
several months ago
uh when uh the proper or the the
the bill in that in texas eight eight
was uh uh i just i'm having brain farts
here but where the bounty hunter bill
right
right or someone's for someone's
pregnancy for someone's abortion um when
that started to take hold i i surmised
that the right to life movement never
really wanted to blame the woman
for the abortion or the pregnancy they
never they always stopped short of that
right that was like that was a bridge
too far they wouldn't blame her they
wouldn't criminalize it
and the reason why is because they know
what kind of movement would be created
against them if they started to
criminalize this yeah and the reason why
is because there's things like eptopic
pregnancies there's things that there's
procedures that women have to have to
save their own life where the pregnancy
isn't a pregnancy it's not a pregnancy
anymore
right right yeah so they always stop
short of that yeah they uh yeah i think
it's it's difficult while they have you
know women in in in the republican party
who are very much like no you know no
pregnancy or no abortion the only time
you're pregnant like is
is you're gonna have the kid right
there's no
no no spectrum of uh like uh
you know maybe something happened you
know whatever but at the same time it's
like that you know
women are
are
being made the villain here right it's
it
or their body right or you know however
you want to phrase it
but they have to bear the punishment
and
the responsibility when it's not their
fault right it could be accidental for
many reasons and especially those ones
where it's like rape or incest or
something like that
and they're like
[Laughter]
what you're gonna have that kid and it's
like right what are you
what kind of
just vile evil person are you that you
would just force a woman to have a baby
because they don't have to but right
right so have you seen have you seen the
video of this [ __ ] idiot in missouri
my home state the city of missouri where
the legislator asked him if he knew he
even knows what a [ __ ] eptopic
pregnancy is he's like nope don't give a
[ __ ] don't care no i haven't here yeah
there's a video of the guy who's [ __ ]
supporting the bill
to make it to where you can't have an
eptopic pregnant
a medical procedure to save your life in
missouri because of an ectopic pregnancy
it says that in the [ __ ] legislation
a woman legislator asked him
point blank pretty much do you know what
an eptop pregnancy is and he says nope
don't know don't give a [ __ ] why would i
care i'm not gonna have one it's got
pregnancy we might as well just rename
it something to have like uh like
ammunition pregnancy or right yeah uh
you know hey that's a good idea gun
pregnancy you know something like that
snap stuff like that right right yeah
you know it's got those things in there
that they would actually like oh
whoa wait a second wait a second you
mean guns and pregnancy are the same
thing well we gotta we gotta stop that
but yeah they they very much are the
group that will
uh you know
they will place
they will victim blame right that's what
they do they they will put
responsibility and ownership on
the woman in this scenario which is
totally
not right at all it's very [ __ ] up um
and will continue to to
to distance themselves and place blame
and not say instead of like hey we don't
really have a good health care system
right we don't really have a good way of
of preventing or
or advocating for women's rights on on a
health side because you know what we
we took away the funding
or you know or it's like hey listen
you're gonna have kid and they're like
okay well do i get like assistance or
like help or education and they're like
what
no no no we're we're we're not gonna do
that so it's like well then
if you're gonna force me as a woman to
have this child
then i feel like you should be forced to
give me assistance
to support and raise that child to be
another member of society nope but if
you're going to rip those benefits and
deny me of those rights and then say hey
not only are we going to make you have
this kid but we're going to make you
raise this kid and potentially a a uh
under the poverty line because you don't
have aid we're potentially going to make
it more difficult for you to get a job
and get uh
unemployment or or financial aid in some
way uh because you're lazy but it's like
but we also just forced you to have a
kid for nine months so there's a whole
yeah i think it's i think it's much more
i think it's much deeper than that
because look here
robin says this will lead to
criminalizing a woman to have a
miscarriage just like other
authoritarian countries right robin
you're right and here's here's the rub
here's the thing here is we're looking
at mike flynn saying ukraine's
independence is not vital to the united
states
authoritarianism spreading around the
world is not vital
to united states and western democracy
that's what an authoritarian would say
right
michael or yeah general michael fl and i
and i use a general in quotes here
because i don't really look at him as a
general uh
uh you know he's a traitor right and he
should be stripped
of all things that he has been given
from a a military background
and for someone who says
oh you know what
ukraine situation and independence
doesn't have anything to do with america
it actually really [ __ ] does because
what it does is we're setting a
precedent for what's acceptable in the
world
as a whole right right if it's saying
yeah russia you can go in and you can
kill these people and you can just take
over because you say it's yours
what's to stop russia from doing that
from someone else well what's that in
china do it to taiwan what to stop it
from another country or another
superpower saying you know what uh
that's mine and no taxi backsies right
what's what's what's to stop a former
president who wants to be the president
2024 to say you know what russia did it
why can't i take canada why can't i take
mexico why can't i why can't i expand my
empire to
to make my fascist state that i want
to be dictorial i mean here you see he
says mike blinn says what if putin
decides to attack one of these ukrainian
nato member states for transferring arms
in ukraine that are killing russian
soldiers as if ukraine is the aggressor
here right
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's like the reason why russian
soldiers are getting killed is because
they're the aggressor
right
that's like you you have a toxic
relationship right and a woman is trying
to get out of it and then obviously the
man is the aggressor and a friend says
hey i'm gonna help you by giving you
money so you can go uh seek shelter
somewhere else or whatever and then
that friend getting penalized for it
because they're like this is a really
[ __ ] up situation and no one else is
helping out and the other person that's
willing to put themselves out there is
myself just in the in the smallest
amount of aid whether it's advice
support money whatever and then that
person is the person that ends up
getting
uh
it sounds with kick it sounds real
familiar like victim blaming like you
know oh yeah if a woman you know may
have been raped or something and then
they're like well maybe maybe you just
you know
what what were you wearing when it
happened right right exactly
what yeah what were you doing wrong what
was ukraine doing wrong that pissed off
vladimir putin right really that's what
authoritarian breeds and if you don't if
you don't think you don't think for one
second because gabe you said well if we
have these these children and you know i
have
listen you know what they're gonna do
with people who can't afford their
children they're gonna put them in camps
that's what they're gonna do that's what
they do they already proved that during
the trump administration when they were
locking children in cages right for
crying out loud i mean i'm telling you
i'm telling you they're going after
children they're going after women and
they'll be after you next
you next and
alls it takes is a little bit of them
knowing they can take away liberty
without consequence and they'll take
away more liberty and they'll take away
more people's liberty and more groups
liberty little by little by little until
they have a fascist state and that's
what's at risk mike flynn right and i
call them because here you know you look
at this stuff and michael mike flynn
goes like well you know
uh what's you know
republicans
even though they know
they know 10 steps ahead what their plan
is right they're like if we take this
right away and we restrict access to
this and we deny you this and we do this
we know by the end we're we're moving
the chess pieces around to say that now
we've got this this precedent in place
where we can say you're jailed or
punished for whatever
so for them to say
uh
guys it's not a big deal like we
shouldn't do this
no no no
they know exactly what they're doing and
exactly what they're saying but right
now they're trying to make it seem like
it's not such a big deal right it's not
going to have some domino effect that
we've already anticipated and we're the
person that's setting up the dominoes
and also simultaneously pushing the
dominoes while you're over there trying
to figure out what's still going on we
know exactly what the play is we know
exactly what we wanted to go and and
we're just
you know we're we're not trying to
instigate it but in the background we
are right like that's what they're doing
well i mean putin it's the same here
here let me show you putin just wants to
take his country back listen to this
everyone thought they'd go in very
quickly that occupy and put it back into
russia like the soviet union they wanted
to rebuild the soviet union without
probably with a different name and all
likelihood but they wanted to build
rebuild the soviet union that's what
this is all about to a large extent and
then you say what's the purpose of this
they had a country you could see it was
a country where there's a lot of love
and
you know we're doing it because somebody
wants to make
uh his country larger or he wants to put
it back the way it was when actually it
didn't work very well
and i it's just a terrible situation
what what in the [ __ ] number one what
the [ __ ] is he talking about the putting
the country and with a lot of love
putting it back the way it was
again this is this is the same thing you
were just saying it's the small
justification
of why we're doing this and that's and
and and that's good enough for us
damn the fascism right damn it also i
didn't i saw that patriot takes had
shared that i didn't even listen to it
this morning because i was like i don't
know if i want to wake up to
to jeans uh to voice her voice in
trump's voice right now but what i will
say is like
that rationale is so ridiculous to be
like well he just wants to make the
country big again you know and not to
say that i haven't heard like oh he
wants to make russia great again right
like that's what it is and he's like oh
he just wants ukraine back he wants a
part of the soviet union look guys guys
don't worry about he's just making sure
that everyone is covered right that's
that's what i'm hearing right now is
that trump looks at it and he's
justifying them to say oh no don't worry
about it uh oh all vlady daddy over
there is doing is he's just taking them
under his wing and making sure that
they're cared for because they weren't
cared for under the democratic state
that they were in they have to come
under us right because we need to force
it the fascism right yeah i mean they
need an authoritarian to tell them what
to do
just like just like this [ __ ] i've got
a couple clips i want to play of his
supporters this is why this is why
tucker carlson can get away with what
he's doing uh why oan newsmax this is
why these people can get away with what
they're doing because the tail is
wagging the dog listen to the tail here
when it came out it was corona right
yeah
corona is six letters six of them
when you use sumatra and use
okay okay well one second do you know
what gematria is because i'm not really
uh keen on the whole i heard her say
that last night and it's right i think
it's a it's a uh it's a numerology or
something like that like um
is it is this kind of like the the whole
uh um
the the the sign thing what your what
your sign is based on your birthday kind
of thing or is this yeah well what it's
doing is like it it's uh i forget is it
well here let's let's let's listen let's
listen to this bonehead describe it
maybe she can
uh uh help us here okay a is one b is
two c is three oh okay and you put
corona lined out at six six so that's
six six six but wait i don't know where
you got the extra six months right wing
crazies found it out so they changed it
to cover 19.
oh so the right-wing crazies figured out
that that corona
it means six six six is that what she's
saying so yeah she's saying that yeah so
yeah so she's so she's using this
numerology to assign
uh letters to numbers right so it's like
one
all the way to 26. and she's just
wait she's assuming that they were so
smart that they figured out the code
that liberals were like oh no we're
going to change things we're like listen
uh
so we're going to decipher this and like
oh my god how dumb are they all right
and yeah so well let's let's continue to
listen to the tale here which is c what
is this c right
it's a c huh
look it up hovid open means sheep this
is not true this is not true no language
ovid means
sheep
why i mean she read it but gabe gabe she
read it on facebook god damn it it has
to be [ __ ] true they can't post
anything on facebook that isn't true god
damn it they can't put anything in that
ivermectin basically i don't i don't
know where they got it probably that but
ovid does not mean sheep okay it's ovus
o-v-i-s
okay is sheep
yeah
there is no ovid in any other language
well i mean there is it's kovid and if
you break it up there is an ovid it's
not sheep but it is ovid i mean if you
broke the the word up i mean anyway for
those for those who actually want to
know
there is no such thing as ovid that
means speech it's ovus in latin that
means sheep so
you know
that's that's strike one okay that's the
first strike i've said
come on the first strike all right let's
keep going 19
military code for surrender
c
sheep
surrender
c
oh i see so c for covid sheep ovid and
then oh i see the code see i didn't i
didn't know the soros code maybe that's
why we haven't been getting our checks
yeah you know what i think yeah i think
we've been putting in the wrong uh
account number right that's possible
maybe you're right we should have been
typing i also don't know if that's true
either i'm not in the military but i'm
sure a quick google search would give
you the answer
and i'm gonna say even if it is even if
it is i mean maybe maybe you're right
maybe the reason why we haven't got our
source check yet is because we've been
typing in the on our antifa app that
we've got maybe we've been typing in the
wrong
the wrong uh code to get our check to us
this is ridiculous wow that that is
actually the first i've heard of that
yeah a lot of people too he's like wow
wow that's incredible yeah that that is
something
it's something to see
it's so crazy because
the the dumbest thing here is that i
i made a vid okay so i've made a a
couple videos about or a few videos
about these like tin foil hat people
that are like
connecting these conspiracies
and one of them one of them was about
cover 19 right and he was exp and the
guy was like explaining
uh the reason for all of those um
uh do you remember the the those
the the
triangular uh
[Music]
i'm blanking on the name but the
structures that showed up all around the
world there were the metal structures oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right
yeah so
uh i made a i made a joke about how they
were connected right it was by aliens
and they were they were used as deposits
for all the vaccines right and that's
how many they were in existence i think
i remember this video yeah right i made
another one that was about sydney powell
and she was saying how
uh there was voter fraud and it was all
george soros and she connected to the
1998 summer
home run
uh
uh competition between mark maguire and
sami sosa and went to 666 which is mark
of the beast right and it was like oh
sammy sosa is from dominican republic
aka dominion software so like this stuff
is
is so it feels so crazy because like
last year i was making jokes about this
and then you fast forward and these
people are literally trying to pull out
they're saying
they're saying it and the thing is like
that one wasn't even about vaccines that
was just about the goddamn voter like
do you think maybe some people saw your
video like on tick tock they're like oh
my god part of me
okay there's a party where i'm like i
really hope that people don't watch my
videos and take it as fact because
well i mean we did the trucker convoy we
did the trucker convoy thing and there
were some people that were like
where are these letters coming where did
you find these like oh my god
we're making them up it's all it's still
there there's a third one there's a
third one coming out too oh really
really yeah okay
i had some people they intercepted a
letter
okay it was an authentic letter okay
okay
from the encampment because now it's in
something yeah because now yeah they're
good yeah camp tyranny good why i look
forward to uh do the maybe the audio
letters that you have intercepted here's
another speaking of um speaking of
lunatics uh walter did a video because i
think um uh the good liars were at the
rally walter was at the rally um and
this is this one's look at all those
flags it is [ __ ] right it's it's um it
really does look like al qaeda um but
let's have a good idea what's going on
in ukraine oh yeah and they went into
ukraine and they found these labs
they believed that made that the
deep state
is
possibly going to use a bio weapon on
russian people because they've been just
like okay first off this bio lab thing
it is not true right right right it's
it's been debunked tucker carlson
well here's here's the thing they do
because i think we were talking about
this yesterday and the day before and
the day before that like they take they
take this little nugget of truth right
which there are things called bio labs
right in every country there we have bio
labs
here
here we have bio labs and what they're
doing in these bio labs is to make sure
that they can fend off viruses i don't
know like you know a 666 c uh c what was
it it was c ovid c ovid c c sheep
surrender type virus that's what it is a
c sheep surrender type viruses
fast right yeah no
but there are bio labs so they have they
they latch on to this little nugget of
truth and then they spend this whole
propaganda conspiracy theory chemtrail
[ __ ] all around it right and it's it's
[ __ ] it's bonkers but listen to what
she says about the virus which is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah i had not heard
this one until she said it this is great
we're collecting our dna in china
they've been collecting their dna as
well
so trump and putin right now are the
only ones successfully fighting against
the deep state i think as well as chi-2
what
xi jinping
so xi jinping is
fighting against the he's a good guy oh
oh he's fighting against well think
about it he's not part of the ccp
look at walter's face he's like what in
the [ __ ] are you talking about lady yeah
like
how in the how in the [ __ ] how in the
[ __ ] can they know this much like
literally they know who these players
are yeah they know putin they know xi
jinping they know trump they know they
know something about geopolitics
up until the point to where you have to
know the most important part who's the
baddies what movie is it from like are
we the baddies are we there oh yeah are
am i the villain
right yeah you are
you you
you are not you are not the good guys it
gets better here with walter
xi jinping do you think he's working
with putin and trump against the deep
state i think he probably is yeah
probably i've heard that yeah i mean
yeah i just heard it too
like i just heard from the guy
from the lady in the first clip i heard
it i just i love how walter goes in
right he's got a loose idea of like all
right he's got like there's a benchmark
each time like a new benchmark is set
each time he goes to a rally right or
with things he sees online he's like all
right great so there's a bio labs we'll
go with that we'll see what people say
and he goes wow this is [ __ ] crazy
i'm now gonna pivot and take this
over to this other conversation and just
right out of the gate so do you think
that they're in cahoots and she's like
yeah i everyone here is saying it
everyone here everyone
everyone's saying many people are saying
it many people are saying it holy [ __ ]
let's let's continue king is working
against the deep state
in india yeah i've heard that xi jinping
vladimir putin i'm surprised they know
all these leaders names working against
the deep state right and then you've got
the white hat alliance which is a lot of
countries you know
the white hat alliance white hat
alliance like white what the [ __ ] is
that like
i'm not blown up on my i'm not bummed up
on my conspiracy theories what's the
white hat alliance what is this sounds
like the kkk well i mean hood hat it's
it's close right i think what is this
white hat [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this is
this some kind of facebook [ __ ] uh
well there's a company called white hat
alliance which is loosely associated
with ethical hacking so that's how i
know i know white hats as ethical
hackers so i don't know if she's saying
like
uh
the white hat alliance are hackers that
are also involved in this
which is interesting because they would
be against these people you know
right i i'm not sure let's continue uh
see with because i think it goes back to
the first lady here canada
uh france he is part of the good guys
the reason i think that is because he's
just gonna go into taiwan you wait and
see what i tell you when he gets into
taiwan guess what he's gonna find
more labs more bio labs that is all
planned out y'all
it's all planned one big sting operation
it's a big sting operation
do they even know what a steam operation
is i'm done i am done tony i quit i quit
the show's over i'm done i cannot
believe the world anymore we can't make
videos anymore bye so i see you later
we can't make videos anymore like
literally that that is what i'm saying
when i when i shared that good liars
video yesterday which was about the
woman who was like oh you gotta go
uh you
is it the mars ones is the mars one no
it it well i'm just saying like the the
the woman in the previous video she was
talking about the c ovid 19 all that
[ __ ] right
uh i believe these people
have killed they they
they took satire out back they
chloroformed it
they beat it over the head with the
shovel
they made it you know
they put it in the [ __ ] wood chipper
they yeah they put it in the wood
chipper then they spread it out on the
on
in the sod and they let it grow and this
[ __ ] just
blew up like weeds
and now
we've got all these other people and
then those seeds spread out and went
somewhere else
and that's what happened satire just
like
blew into the wind and spread everywhere
else and now it's no longer satire
because now you have to you have to
question everything you hear
and it's like are those
it's like is that a joke
is that not a joke
i've been saying it forever wrestlemania
real life that's the intersection that
we're at
yeah that's the intersection let's
finish this i got one more video i want
to play before you head out yeah that's
what i believe yeah so xi jinping
putin and trump are the only ones
fighting uh against the deep state and
making sure that there are no bio
weapons that's right because if they do
not stop them they will release them
and next time it'll be far worse than
any fake chronovalves the fate it'll be
far worse than any fake coronavirus okay
wait wait a sec it'll be far worse than
any fake
coronavirus this is the same [ __ ] when
people say covet 19 was a hoax but then
also acknowledged that people died from
covid by saying covid wasn't as bad as
uh the flu
right the flu was worse but cove is a
hoax covert was made in a lab which is
it was it made in the lab
was it a hoax is it is it not as bad as
the flu like you guys got to either
acknowledge that covet is real and say
people are dying because of it or say
covet isn't real and people are dying
for some other weird reason but you get
you can't have one or the other right
you can't say it's fake and then release
it
i
don't i don't know i have i can't i
can't put it together here's another
video from the good liars this is from
the other day at the event remember uh
eric trump spoke at uh
the event he he speaks at those like
right and he says weird church events
a lot and
as if he's some kind of [ __ ]
religious person in the first place but
anyways we're going to get to eric trump
later but this is an event that he spoke
at but these people here
apparently think a certain thing about
nazis and mars let's listen to what they
have to say you hear elon musk talking
about us going to mars
mars colonized exactly
what
did
he steps away and he's like
what like like he can't even keep his
composure so like
so this guy is literally just saying
this guy's literally saying that there
are human beings that live on mars see
this this is all [ __ ] backwards to
what conspiracy spirit theories are
supposed to believe we are actually
supposed to believe that that that we
didn't go to the moon right like that's
the conspiracy
that's the one you're supposed to leave
that we didn't go to space
right like not that we have a colony on
mars
if we had a county in mars i would i
would i was like yep cool i'm going by i
want to leave now like i want to leave
this place this is crazy
it did it
let's let's continue to listen and again
i want to go back to wrestlemania real
life look at this gay there's been there
are millions of americans that live on
mars oh my goodness yeah they bring you
know the brain drains he's won the war
and they gave up the country of germany
but the nazis all came over here and now
they were they're all for the u.s
government george w bush the leader of
the fourth right really yeah a lot more
going on wait wait jordan jordan h
h w bush is the leader of the leader of
the third right
fourth reich
hw is right yeah he said yeah yeah he
said he's got to know who hw is as
opposed to w because he said hw yeah he
said hw
he's got to know that george h.w bush
is is not alive right is this jfk junior
type [ __ ] yeah see here's the thing if
you've if you've accepted a reality
where millions of americans live on
another planet
and nazis won the war exactly and and
the idea that george h.w bush was the
leader of the fourth reich then yeah
tony he's still [ __ ] alive get it
together accept this reality we live in
is this one of those [ __ ] timelines
where you know those books where you're
like you get to pick your own you get to
be like an arl stein goosebumps story
right right you get to write your own
story and it's a different story every
time so like did these people read a
book somewhere like uh what if this
would have happened they're like oh that
actually right sounds [ __ ] rory
nazi uh germany would still exist today
right like it would you know who would
transfer power it would have gone from
hitler to george h.w bush
clearly that is the succession clearly
like clearly
this makes
all of the sense tony it makes all the
sense and millions of americans have
been flown and now colonized mars and
you know what the movie uh
we can't even we can't even clown these
[ __ ] anymore man
it's it's we're it's broken the timeline
someone at home office please if you're
listening unplug the [ __ ] timeline
and plug that [ __ ] back in we
are we are off the grid here i i just
feel like
uh if i showed them the scene from total
recall at the end where arnold
schwarzenegger goes out into mars he's
like
and then like you know puts his hand
down to like purify the air whatever
happens
uh they would go like yeah that's that's
historically accurate
like that's what that's the world we
live in where those people you'd be like
hey check out this work of fiction and
they're like fiction that's a [ __ ]
documentary bro and you're like
but but man the thing is
these people are out walking around they
got jobs and they're they're like it's
it's it's disturbing to know
that like not not that they that that
these people just live amongst us is
that they're not getting the help they
need like we need mental health care and
and this video is proof of that let's
continue to watch
for 16 years and i walked away and it
was 2006 when i realized the whole
machine screw up these guys
he's not wrong about that
no no no absolutely he's he
and all of that [ __ ] that he said
there i love i love the i love the
ending here yeah
there was some truth at the end there
which was about they're criminals
corrupt politicians and criminals
totally totally agree totally agree it's
broken however uh him jumping to
millions of americans or people have
colonized mars
that's a big jump baby
well probably as far as the distance
from earth to mars
and the dead the dead [ __ ] keeper h.w
bush is somehow the leader of the fourth
reich i i can't
it's jfkgs
who
like is this a psyop by someone is
someone just [ __ ] with these people
i don't know and they're like they're
like on a board and they're like all
right okay so today i had a croissant
now how do we tie in croissants with the
fourth reich okay look it's kind of it's
kind of shaped this way like a like a
moon like a crescent moon but you know
what else that happened on the moon or
rather what didn't happen on the moon
the moon landing that was all an inside
job done by nasa done by the government
you know what else was done by the
government and then they just go from
there and then they say oh well george a
w bush was actually the leader of the
fourth reich like you could pull
anything out and then say that it's all
connected what don't you remember during
9 11 and michael moore did fahrenheit
911 um which is a decent movie but
there's some parts of it you're like
michael you're full of [ __ ] like you're
just you're completely full of [ __ ] like
that's not even how it works not even
close basically saying that the bush
family was kind of behind 911 right yeah
making that like no i mean as as cool as
that sounds and as good as a story that
might be that's that's not how it
happened there are there are logical and
really easy conclusions that you can
draw from the evidence that's there
this person this person is way off that
map like way way way off that map
from even from even the 911 conspiracy
theories yeah i think yeah i think you
have to jump i i wish we could you have
to jump because you know what i have to
catch my flight back to the mars colony
so okay good good good well uh make sure
make sure you get the code right next
time when you're entering in for our
soros checks right we really we really
need that that um
the sea
sheep surrender money we need that so i
got some money i gotta really study up
on that numerology yeah um
apologies apologies i'll get it right
next time and i'll make sure that our
checks get through so okay good well
everyone stick around uh gabe's going to
mars but we
we will be right back after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim gyms skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
[ __ ]
back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
i heard part one
of the trucker letters from the trucker
convoy there
um i think i think gabe said we're gonna
have part three maybe here soon maybe
we'll release that today if we can
unearth
those found letters
from the from the trucker convoy we also
had part two maybe we'll play part two
again um i i love those videos they're
they're doing fantastic they're super
funny um joe joe is a fantastic writer
and uh how we put those how gay put
those videos together is is [ __ ]
fantastic so go support the uh
the trucker convoy the trucker convoy uh
videos wherever wherever you find the
content whether it's on my page gabe's
page the podcast page joe's got it over
on her page
um so go check that out we have more
traitors of democracy to talk about here
this morning on fox
fox and friends
we had brian kill me and apparently
blaming the united states as the
aggressor
for the war and year and let's let's
listen to this [ __ ] idiot i don't
know if you look at that map and and the
areas that they have that you say could
end up in this piece agreement that's
true and that's why we should have never
provoked them i mean they made very
clear that there was a red line the red
line was a neutrality for ukraine that
they could not enter nato and in the end
when they get this if they get this
peace agreement in the end that's
probably going to end up being the case
anyway i bet 10 i bet i bet you that one
of the conditions will have to be that
ukraine you know promise to remain
neutral will not be part of nato well
i'll tell you what you could never give
in to what russia wants other nations to
do uh you you decide they're going to
decide you're going to nato you go into
the european union when they're at their
european society that wants that well we
have a we have a monroe doctrine and i
think we would be very concerned about
this kind of action in our hemisphere i
think he said
keep it neutral and and in the end
probably ukraine is going to lose more
land because of this again
the the main problem here as you see and
as we discussed well no actually the
main problem is still china and now
we've created a bigger block china and
russia together this is why our
policymakers aren't thinking long term
right provoking this this war has
brought our two enemies closer together
i i apologize to brian kilmeade here
because what he just said is we did not
provoke the war
um this bonehead whoever she is in the
middle i don't know who she is
i have no idea i have no idea who she is
um she's the one who said we provoked
the war the united states provoked
vladimir putin
to invade ukraine
what in the [ __ ] are you talking about
we did everything we could for him not
to do that we warned him of what would
happen if he did do that
we were like yeah we're going to
sanction the [ __ ] out of you like it'll
be really bad for your economy like
we'll tank a ruble like it'll be
non-existent almost you won't even be
able to open your stock market
[ __ ] we will also sanction
oligarchs around the world and not only
will the eu be behind us well so will
nato and other countries around the
world will be behind us we'll go look
for oil someplace else as well
while while we put up with higher higher
crew prices
because of your supply we will cut you
off like they warned them they warned
them for weeks and months
joe biden the president united states
the state department and our our
administration in this country has been
saying this
for [ __ ] months
even even legitimate real reporters were
scoffing at the administration saying ah
putin's not going to invade he's not
going to invade and the administration's
like nope he's gonna do it and we're
planning on him doing it and here's what
we're gonna do if he does do it and this
is what we're telling him we're gonna do
if he does it
then he did it
i don't know who the [ __ ] she is i have
no idea who the [ __ ] she is
i have no clue
who the [ __ ] she is but why in the [ __ ]
she's allowed to talk into a microphone
on a place that claims to be news is
beyond me
the [ __ ] tucker carlson of the
morning here
united states provoked the war in
ukraine get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] it
is [ __ ]
you know you're on the wrong [ __ ]
page when brian killed me has a little
bit of throw up in his mouth and he has
to correct you on fox news
that's when you know you're on the wrong
[ __ ] page
that's really ridiculous
uh let's see here what else do we have
under brian kill me of course there's
the same
the same clip
uh again i apologize to kill me this
time this time only [ __ ] this time i
have to take each circumstance
you know individually here
because brian killed me is a [ __ ]
bonehead so you can't you can't just
assume
okay here's
apparently her name
is rachel campos duffy
so rachel here
campos is that anything campos duffy
rcd
who the [ __ ] is that who is she
i don't know who she is
why the [ __ ] she's on fox and friends i
don't know
i don't know i think we all know
this [ __ ] bonehead
is brainwashed in the thinking that
that the united states
the united states provoked putin
you're a traitor
rachel
you're a [ __ ] traitor
to democracy
traitors to democracy put rachel on the
[ __ ] list today put her on the
[ __ ] list
i wonder why kill meat is trending
though i guess kill means trending
because no one knows who the [ __ ] campos
duffy is
all right the canadian parliament
ukrainian president uh uh vladimir
zelinsky addresses
the parliament of canada on tuesday um
that's a really long video that's the
whole thing let's see if we can get a
clip of it here
uh in translation
uh there he is welcoming
uh this is this is prime minister justin
trudeau
uh welcoming
uh we'll go with the recounts video here
of it
here is
him introducing zielinski apparently
let's let's listen in well ludamir in
the years i've known you i've always
thought of you as a champion for
democracy
and now oh this is really going to piss
off madison gothard this is going to
piss off manny calzorn
that that justin trudeau is
is praising the thug zilinski
for for being a champion of democracy do
you see the [ __ ] theme here
these [ __ ] idiots hate democracy
madison cawthorne marjorie taylor green
matt gatz joe kent who's running in
washington's third
lauren bobert donald trump
steve bannon they're the [ __ ] bad
guys michael flynn
roger stone the oath keepers the proud
boys the republican [ __ ] party
vladimir putin
is the puppet master
of all these traitors to democracy
because ultimately as i've been saying
over and over and over and over again
putin's aim here with ukraine
is not land it's not a real estate deal
trump you dumb [ __ ]
it's to undermine
democracy
that is the goal that is the aim
to take away what is so precious to
everyone their [ __ ] liberty
you take away their liberty you have
power over them
hell you can kill them you can make sure
that it's illegal for them to cross a
state line if they need a medical
procedure
i mean you can kill them you can execute
them in certain states if they have to
have a medical procedure to save their
life
you can execute them
you can make sure that if a person has a
certain sexual
identity
that they are ostracized from society
if they question their identity they're
ostracized
if they're a person of color if they're
bipark
ostracized that makes it really simple
under authoritarianism makes it really
simple under fascism for white people to
have their grievance
and not only have their grievance but
act on it
and that is the rub here
zelinski
is
pro-democracy even as even as corrupt
and unperfect as ukrainians democracy is
he still
pro-democracy
and that
is why madison cawthorne hates stalinski
that is why donald trump hates zielinski
that's why the republican party is
behind putin
that's why
and that's why all these sheep out there
think that the gas prices are joe
biden's fault because joe biden why
wouldn't you buy oil from putin putin is
the good guy
putin's a good guy why wouldn't you buy
oil from the good guy
because they [ __ ] hate democracy they
[ __ ] hate it and the reason why they
hate it
is because it doesn't fit their fascism
democracies around the world are lucky
to have you
as our champion
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
below demir
and that is applause for democracy
democracy is [ __ ] hard it's really
[ __ ] hard it is not [ __ ] easy
and the reason why it's not easy is
because not everyone agrees on every
subject and every length of that subject
every measure of that subject jesus
christ we see it in the big ten
pro-democracy party of the democrats in
this day and age
as we invite more people into the big
tent as more people leave the fascist
party that is the gqp the death cult
the trump death cult that is the fascist
regime
of the gqp who are putin's puppets
as they leave that party they only have
one place to [ __ ] go
when they're pro-democracy in this day
and age
is to caucus with the democrats whether
that means you're republican not
you're a never trumper you're a moderate
you're an independent
hell you're a socialist you're a
democratic socialist you're a liberal
you're a leftist
you're a democrat
big d
card holding democrat
there is way more
of us who believe in democracy
than those who don't
and it is up to us it is up to us to
fight every single inch and every single
millimeter every
[ __ ] last
one of them
just like those ukrainians are doing now
and i wish they didn't have to fight the
way they had to fight
against
a fascist
murderous dictator that is vladimir
putin who is trying to destroy what
democracy they have what democracy that
they've worked for
and all you fascists out there
who call us a republic and think putin's
awesome and putin's so tough
if you're on the side of trump
putin bannon if you if you are on their
side
you are the baddies you're not the good
guys you're the bad guys you're the ones
who end up in bunkers you're the ones
who end up on nuremberg trials with war
crimes that's who you're with you stupid
[ __ ]
you're with the nazis
you are
so
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
and figure out
why democracy works for everyone it's
not easy it's not easy and you got to
lay things aside like your hatred for
women like you you know you just got to
give that up
your hatred for women your hatred for
lgbtq bypoc people you got to give that
up
you got to give up your hatred just a
little bit to be part of democracy
otherwise you're going to be [ __ ]
miserable
you're going to be completely [ __ ]
miserable so just
stop the big government stuff where you
want to take away [ __ ] people's
liberty
take away people's rights and freedom
just give that up and come over and try
democracy for a little bit just a little
bit
besides
there there's nothing better than a
diverse party
what i mean by that is
race gender
religion
let's have a big [ __ ] party and let's
celebrate everyone equality and equity
because the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people
is not
liberty
when vladimir putin thinks he has the
freedom to oppress the rights of the
ukrainians
that
is not
liberty
when when putin's puppets in texas
decide that they're going to oppress the
rights
of women by threatening the death
penalty on them if they receive a
medical procedure
that is not
liberty
and that is what democracy delivers us
through rights and freedoms is the
vehicle that delivers us
liberty and it's not perfect
it's not
when you look at ukraine it's not
[ __ ] perfect
it's not it won't be perfect
it's not gonna be
democracy will never be perfect for
every single person in that democracy
but everyone should have the liberty
everyone
every last [ __ ]
every last
[ __ ]
stay right here
don't go anywhere we'll be back right
after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
hanging through the break
thanks for hanging through the break
one of these days these commercials will
have these commercial breaks will have
sponsors in them what do you guys think
about that who should who should sponsor
us you guys got any good good products
that you guys like to use that you guys
want to see sponsor us here on the tony
michaels podcast uh to hear it here i'll
do the youtube thing go down and comment
down below and put your comment who you
like to sponsor i don't know
go do that if you want
whoever you want to sponsor us
if you got a product that you like or a
product that you want to see i don't
know
you know whatever it is whatever it is
let us know all right let's go back um
this is actually this is jake tapper cnn
um it's kind of a long
uh video here
but uh he goes through
it says cnn jtapper examines former
president donald trump's history of
siding with uh russian president
vladimir putin despite russia's repeated
aggression um this does a very good job
of breaking it down
so i want to um
i want to
make sure that
adam and eve you want to see adam and
eve ads i'm i'm not scared of an adam
and eve we'll do adam and eve condoms
sure why not i'm i'm down it doesn't
make me any difference
we'll we'll we'll do we'll do any any
good ol any good old product that needs
to be these are things that you have to
have right i mean these are
these are these are viable products
these are viable sponsors
i appreciate you guys listening and i
appreciate you guys uh participating in
the chat it's always fun having you guys
here remember we have super chat now
don't forget that if you want to support
the show i always love that you guys
like share um subscribe follow
everyone does such a great job of
of uh helping us get the the word out
about the show and i do appreciate it
and if you'd like to help support
um the show as well you can go to the
super chat you can also go to
thetonymichaels.com
you can uh give to the podcast up refund
and there's the merch stores that help
us as well uh gabe's merch stores there
our merch store is there uh so it's all
there go follow us on all the channels
if you don't download us on apple
spotify or google even if you have those
things available go give us a rating
over there that'll help us out
and tell us about your friends or tell
tell your friends about us that's not
tell us about your friends tell your
friends about us about the show every
single weekday new knees turn 11 central
right here on youtube twitter and twitch
so go to thetonymichaels.com follow all
that stuff send that link to all your
friends
you know spam email or something i'm
just kidding don't don't spam email your
friends
maybe send them a text or something now
get give them the youtube link
let them get a little taste thank you
very much midas midas lisa
we appreciate you guys being here and
giving the super chat the super stickers
the super chat we really really really
do appreciate it every single time let's
listen let's listen a little bit what uh
jake has to say here
about donald trump
and vladimir putin's
their their love life
as it were
their love life
in our world the war in ukraine is
entirely the fault and responsibility of
one man vladimir putin though of course
decades of misjudgments
in western foreign policy set the stage
for him as we have covered before
recently however former president donald
trump and his allies have been engaging
in quite a bit of revisionist history
about this matter
this is so sad because this would have
never happened if we had the trump
administration there was no chance that
this would happen
and i know him well
and this was not something that was
going to happen at all
trump of course failing to mention there
his own actions and inactions that
and that of his administration that may
have enabled putin in many ways instead
of calling out russia's decades of
invasion in georgia 2008 annexing crimea
from ukraine in 2014 trump to this day
seems to find room to believe putin even
praise him as a genius quote unquote
genius for the brutal attack even some
of trump's former advisors wonder if his
approach may have empowered the russian
president on the world stage
as the world watches russian tanks
rolling into ukraine a clearer picture
comes into focus
not only about vladimir putin's
willingness to slaughter innocence in
the name of restoring the old soviet
empire but also
i would love to be able to get along
with russia about how our former
president consistently sent signals that
he was not on ukraine's side he was on
putin's
on the very day trump announced his
presidential run in 2015 he made this
clear i was over in moscow two years ago
and i will tell you you can get along
with those people and get along with
them well you can make deals with those
people obama can't the way he denigrated
allies and spoke favorably of putin
and of other authoritarians around the
world kind of gave a clear signal both
to american allies in the west and to
russia whose side this man would be on
if he were in the white house
trump said he would be looking into
lifting sanctions against russia for
having annexed crimea and he seemed to
buy putin's argument but russia's first
military assault on ukrainian
sovereignty taking crimea in 2014 was
not such a big deal you know the people
of crimea from what i've heard
would rather be with russia than where
they were that wasn't the issue the
issue was that it was annexed illegally
against all international laws paul
manafort trump's second campaign
chairman had close ties to russia paul
manafort has done an amazing job
manafort was a lobbyist for a
russian-backed ukrainian president i i
think we kind of get the gist here right
i mean like even even in the first the
two minutes
three minutes of the lead up to this
like you know you can out you can
already see where the ball is sitting on
the t
right
for them to be all in with russia it's
not [ __ ] complicated it's not
difficult to understand
now jake tapper does a pretty good job i
will uh i'll retweet this video
um to the top so you guys can find it
you guys can go watch it
i want to move on to a few other things
here in the tweety tweets attorney
trends
before we before we head out for the day
because we're 36 minutes into the second
hour
but
but this really is it really is today's
the theme is traitors to democracy and
it's almost every single day that we
have to deal with this i want to get to
eric trump so uh sorry jake everyone's
saying jake jake is a jackass for uh you
know attacking dems and and and
president biden which uh
the media the media does this stupid
[ __ ] thing where they're like oh we
can't appear to be left wing [ __ ] that
[ __ ] just tell the [ __ ] truth you
ain't got to [ __ ] act like you're
you're trying to be fair and balanced
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's what they tried to
do act like they're fair
balance just go on
go all in
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's what we do here is go all in so
um
just go to uh
jake's i retweeted it uh rachel it looks
like rachel maddow is turning now the
hell is rachel maddow joining war
and to refresh before you liz cheney's
uh trending i want to get to that
was rachel mano trending is she trending
what the hell is she drinking for
what the hell is she trending for
[Laughter]
well let's see here
uh
let's go to the trendy trends here and
see if rachel maddow is popping up
why is rachel maddow trending
i want to see what she said
to be fair i know i don't think she's
trending i think my i think my twitter
was glitching you ever get that
do you ever get that like it sometimes
happens like that right
like you're you're trying to
trying to get going there
oh okay
uh you guys know rachel bitkoffer right
we have rachel on every once a while
trying to get her on this week maybe
uh she wants me to uh
show a new ad that we've get she's got
here
strike packs got a new ad
it looks like it's called america it's
time for choosing
it's time for choosing let's see what
this is about
[Music]
this is genius
putin
is now saying it's independent i said
how smart is that and he's going to go
in and be a peacekeeper
that's the strongest peace for us we
could use that on our southern border
wait a second why is it disloyal to side
with russia
but loyal to side with ukraine i think
it's inarguable
that vladimir putin has been a stronger
leader in his country than barack obama
has been in this country we had a kind
of a really pathetic display from the
ukrainian president zielinski earlier
today he was essentially imploring
vladimir putin not to invade his country
[Music]
what a great video
what a great video she just released it
um go go retweet this thing
go spread it let's get this thing
millions of views
i'm gonna retweet it now
rachel asked me to
play this
spread it around everybody
spread it around the internet like
herpes
please spread it around
like
herpes get the word out
go retweet this it's at the top of the
timeline um i'll go to the show and
retweet it from the show's uh podcast
account as well
um super important to
get the word out
it's time for choosing america what are
you going to choose you're going to
choose putin are you going to choose
democracy which is it because that's
what the republicans want you to choose
the republicans want you to choose to be
with putin which they are
are you going to choose democracy
zielinski's democrat is trending
ooh
it's a linsky democrat
what is this bill crystal says if liz
runs for the republican nomination in
2024 i'll donate oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
i'd vote for her in a virginia primary
if it could make a difference but i'm
doubtful that
will be the case i think it's more
likely that 2024 will be voting
for not for a reagan republican but for
a zelinski democrat
you ask is going to be that zilinski
democrat
no bill
bill bill bill bill this is the liz
cheney thing
jesus christ
um
again
i've been telling you this you gotta
watch out for this liz cheney that's
what she's trying to do
uh let's see is she trending what is she
trending for
uh here you go whoopi goldberg on on the
view defends liz chaney for standing up
against trump's election lie i'm not
saying that's not a good thing
i'm not saying i'm not saying that she
shouldn't [ __ ] tell the truth but
listen
if the [ __ ] standard is that you're
you're a good person and you're a good
republican if you tell the truth do you
understand how [ __ ] low the bar is
do you have any [ __ ] idea how easy it
is for
liz cheney to be a good
a good person if all she has to do is
say what yeah trump didn't [ __ ] win
really
that's it
that's the [ __ ] bar
come on get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
and i i don't like to roast whoopee
goldberg but i have a feeling i'm gonna
have to do it here
and i i'm i'm equal opportunity here
i'll [ __ ] roast you if you have a
dumb [ __ ] take let's listen to whoopi
goldberg has to say about liz cheney i'm
sure it's [ __ ] dumb
what matters to me
is that someone from that end of the
rope said you know this is not okay yeah
this is not okay i can fight
about
our ideals back and forth but when you
poop on the country and say that a lie
is the truth that what we're talking
about isn't important and somebody
stands up and says listen listen i know
you don't like what i'm saying but i'm
going to stand up and say i have to have
to give i'm you know she not never vote
for her she shouldn't get this much
credit
liz cheney that is whoopi did you stop
giving her so much credit just because
she [ __ ] just because she admits that
the big that donald trump didn't win
that's the [ __ ] bard to say oh she's
a good person
every [ __ ] democrat every person out
there with a goddamn
with a mind left that isn't [ __ ]
zapped by facebook or whatever the [ __ ]
these people are zapped by fox news oann
or newsmax understands that trump lost
most people who voted for trump
understand the trump lost i know that's
hard to comprehend
but most people who voted for him under
stupid [ __ ] guys to vote for him who
don't know anything about civics
anything about our country any about our
government still voted for him
they know he lost
it's not a high perc it's not a high
[ __ ] percentage of people in this
country that believe that nonsense it
really isn't it's a large number of
people that's why what is so dangerous
here is that it's so many [ __ ] people
that believe this garbage
it's a large number of people
that bought into that [ __ ]
it's not a large percentage most [ __ ]
reasonable people understand the trump
loss and he's not the president united
states
most people understand it and liz cheney
should not get credit for understanding
that that's really [ __ ] dumb
that's really [ __ ] dumb now i'm not
opposed to her giving her credit when
she's trying to tear down trumpism
in and of itself there's credit where
credit can do but just because she tells
the truth about the big like get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
christina says liz needs to talk with
her vote
she keeps she's voting for trump she's
voting for republicans do you know what
liz cheney didn't vote for
voting rights
liz cheney did not vote
for voting rights
she said no those voting rights things
don't need those [ __ ] that [ __ ]
liz cheney wants to go back to the old
thin bailed fascism
not the outright fascism that we have
now
she wants to go back to the old style
republican fascism whoopi
yeah
yowzas
yowzers given liz cheney credit cause
she
she understands the truth it really is
[ __ ] ridiculous is this why liz
cheney's trending
is this why because people
think that she's a hero because she says
the truth
she says a simple truth that the
majority the percentage-wise the
majority of americans already know and
understand it moved on past
the only truth that we want to know from
liz cheney is from the january 6 select
committee is who committed treason
that's it that's the truth i want to
know [ __ ] the big lie
we all know that's [ __ ] [ __ ] and
that should not be the standard that
should not be the bar
of who's a good [ __ ] politician
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] that
see that's the slow walk to fascism that
we have that's it right there
of course hillary clinton and hunter
bite is twinning
oh
hunter biden's laptop
jesus [ __ ] christ
ugh
it just it never ends it never [ __ ]
ends with this hunter biden [ __ ] or the
hillary clinton [ __ ] for that matter
i mean in all honesty i wonder what i
wonder in all honesty is
because everyone know that that hillary
was right
hillary she was [ __ ] right she was
spot on
she was [ __ ] spot on she was telling
us the whole time this is what's gonna
happen this is what it is
i'm telling you hello she was
waving her arms yelling and screaming
into a microphone they're deplorables
they're gonna [ __ ] side with putin
she was telling us the whole time
i wonder
is hunter biden's laptop
just as adhered
to the truth as hillary clinton like
does hunter biden's laptop no does it
have a crystal ball like hillary clinton
did that's all i
that's all i want to know and i want to
know how much how much it's uh it's it's
drug habits not hunter biden the laptop
the laptop has to do drugs too right
it has to i don't know i'm just
i think maybe maybe i don't know
uh it's equal pay day i don't want to
leave here without without talking about
equal payday it is equal payday
uh in this country this is the the day
march 15th of where a woman catches up
with a man
[Laughter]
with pay
uh i i thought i i i cannot believe that
we even have to have these debates
anymore
this is not this isn't a [ __ ] thing
we should have to [ __ ] debate anymore
it really isn't
that
women should get paid the exact same for
the exact same work
actually frankly women are better at
most [ __ ] they should probably get paid
more
that's
right that's right women should probably
get paid more for the work they do
they're hell of a lot [ __ ] better
than most men at anything anything
really
it's ridiculous
that we have to [ __ ] still debate
this and still have to go round and
round about this this is like the
[ __ ] argument of let people love who
they want to love why the [ __ ] are we
still arguing about this
why
why why are we still arguing about if
you want to love someone just love them
you know ain't got nothing to do with
this guy or that guy or the guy down the
street or whoever just just love the
person you want to love
it really it this these things aren't
complicated and most americans don't
make them complicated
so it's equal pay day the buying
administration is
marking equal pay day with new steps to
end the gender pay gap which is good i'm
glad they're trying to end gender pay
gap
but at this point in 2022 we shouldn't
have to be doing these things including
an executive order that encouraged
banning federal contractors from seeking
information about job applicants prior
salary history
so basically what they're doing is
making sure that your prior salary which
was based on
factors of discrimination because of
your gender shouldn't have anything to
do with your new salary
nothing the salary should be the same
whether you're man woman whoever the
applicant is doesn't matter again i
actually think women should probably get
paid more men
i mean it's about time you know you got
to even [ __ ] out you know history you
know
even the [ __ ] out i'm not saying it's
not like a revenge thing i'm just saying
you're saying
whatever okay let's go back to the
trendy trends and tweety tweets and and
again again it's equal payday so go send
out a tweet for equal payday
um
give it some give it some
some rounds on the tweety tweets and the
trending trends it's at number four
right now so a lot of people are
tweeting about it
um you guys seen
navalny isn't trending anymore
it wasn't trending is he no
no
maybe maybe i don't think so
that's a big story that that vladimir
putin and the the russian courts are
saying 13 more years to keep him silent
they're obviously trying to buy his time
for something i think
i think so
maybe i'm wrong now let's go to the for
you again uh liz cheney
hbcus historical black colleges and
universities is trending
um zelinski democrat kill me trevor noah
what did he say now trevor noah let's
see what hbcu's um why it's trending is
there something uh that's happening in
the news
see if there's some news about it or if
it's just turning because people are
talking about it
it might be um
equal pay days sparking some of this i'm
not sure
why what the oh something about ralph
lauren oh ralph lauren was trending is
that why hbc user trending
see hey you gotta walk around the trends
here this is how you do this yeah here
it is
uh ralph lauren unveils hbcu uh
collection exclusive for more morehouse
and spelman college
uh here it is uh philip lewis has it uh
ralph lauren
unveils hbcu collection exclusive for
morehouse and spelman college
now here's some of the pictures of it
um
i i'm not i'm not a very good dr i don't
know anything about fashion i don't know
i don't know i don't know but i will
tell you that these outfits
look pretty [ __ ] spiffy
i'm not sure about this guy in the
middle here
i don't know if i'd wear those pants but
you know rav lauren knows a lot [ __ ]
more than i do
a lot [ __ ] more than i do
so it looks like ralph lauren is uh
unveiling its collection
of hbcu
so
that looks like why
hbcu is trending
okay let's go back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends see what else is
going on here
um you guys heard that i mentioned
yesterday scott hall
uh the wrestler i i was a fan growing up
at wrestling i was a fan of the the wcw
and nwo
and scott hall was one of the founding
members of the new world order
in the in the wrestling world of uh the
wcw this is why i say
that our our timeline
is is the intersection of wrestlemania
in real life right like that's
and the reason why is because i used to
watch wrestling as a kid
and it was always good
bad guy versus good guy right
it was always that way is that wrestling
that is the
that's the whole storyline
he's good guy
versus bad guy
that's the whole storyline
and too sensationalize and to get more
fans involved
in the timeline or in the in the
storyline or the timeline of the
wrestling of whether it be wcw wwf at
the time or w-e-w now
or n-w-o or
there's all kinds of wrestling leagues
but to actually keep the fans involved
and to grow their fan base
what they started to figure out
when they make these stories up
that's all it is it's made up stories
and then they do their the the wrestling
which is that's the real stuff like when
they're doing the flips and they're
falling on their backs and they're
getting hit with chairs like that's the
real stuff the fake stuff the fake stuff
is the storyline the timeline uh who
wins who loses who's supposed to be the
good guy who's supposed to be the bad
guy that's all the fake [ __ ] right
that's all the made up [ __ ]
the actual wrestling was the real stuff
but what these wrestling
leagues figured out is that you can't
just
you can't just have the real stuff you
got to have the fake stuff to keep the
fans involved and then what they
discovered is wow the fans really like
the bad guys like they like the bad guys
they like them they want to be on their
side like they want to pretend
that the bad guy wins right
like in every [ __ ] story the good
guys always win
and really
in history
like
in the longevity of history
not in short terms but in the long term
of history
the good guy wins
just like we have with ukraine and putin
the good guy is gonna win
no doubt i have no doubt in my mind now
the question is how many people have to
suffer how many people have to die
how many people have to lose their homes
have to lose have to lose
everything
their family
their livelihood their liberty how many
people
have to die
russians ukrainians
and others
but we know with a good guy and who the
bad guy is just like in wrestling we
know who the good guy and who the bad
guy is right we know
we know
who they are
it's not complicated
it's it's not even theoretical we know
who the good guys are
who the bad guys are it's really it's
it's kind of simple
but we see the clips of the good liars
and walter from the from the trump rally
and even from the little [ __ ] mars
and
these people getting all this stuff
turned around in their [ __ ] skulls
we see all this stuff
and it resembles
those story lines in wrestling
good guy
versus bad guy
right
good guy versus bad guy
and these people are predisposed
by stories like professional wrestling
where there's a good guy and a bad guy
right yeah we hear this [ __ ] with guns
good guys at the gun bad guy with a gun
which is all [ __ ]
the bad guy with a gun thinks they're
the good guy
with the gun
in real life not in wrestling but in
real life the bad guy putin
he thinks he's the good guy
in real life the bad guy
the bad guy donald trump
thinks he's the good guy
that that's what happens
that's why the good guy bad guy [ __ ]
is all [ __ ] [ __ ]
thank you robin for the super sticker
appreciate the support
robin's here every day
thank you robin
but we really are at the in the
intersection
of wrestlemania and real life it is a
real thing and on one corner there's the
facebook ivermectin
institute
of dumb [ __ ]
and on the other corner we have putin's
puppet shop
i mean otherwise known as fox news
and that's where we're at in our country
because there is a small
percentage of the population
though albeit it is a small percentage
of the population it is a large number
of people
and the problem with that
is that because that wrestling that
wrestlemania crowd
that wants to make politics
entertainment not real life
they want to make it the good guy bad
guy story like wrestling
make up all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
thinking there's no consequences to
making up crazy ass [ __ ]
the reason why
that is so [ __ ] dangerous
is because
a third party endorsement
what i mean by that it's not third party
like the green party or libertarian
when you have a third party endorsement
when you go look for i don't know a car
and someone says well you should go buy
it from bob down the street he got me a
good deal and then you go and and tammy
says yeah you should go to bob too he
gave me a good deal
that's a third-party endorsement
and the people endorsing these q and on
conspiracy theories spreading it around
and the communities and the churches and
the schools
and spreading their fascism
to people who don't understand that it
is fascism or understand what it is
that is the danger folks that is what
creeps a fascist state
to being a real reality
being complicit
or just not knowing
that's what gets us there so that's what
we're fighting for
and we have to fight every inch every
single millimeter for this democracy and
it's not gonna be easy it's gonna be
hard
but we're gonna keep doing it every
single weekday
right here on youtube twitter twitch
noon eastern
11th central
every [ __ ] weekday
don't miss it go subscribe follow us at
tonymichaels pod
on twitter
and until tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking